the scp foundation is no stranger to
containing dangerous entities capable of
taking lives without discretion but some
of those entities aren't just mindless
monsters they're people with feelings
and desires stuck in an unfortunate
circumstance granted unnatural abilities
by fate or chance for a lot of human
anomalies contained by the foundation
it's not a stretch to say that they most
likely wish they were ordinary like
anyone else that they didn't have to be
locked up in a containment cell for the
rest of their lives as the years have
gone by the foundation much like any
organization has changed a lot more
facilities have pushed for ethical and
humane treatment of anomalies some going
so far as to integrate safe anomalies
into the command structure of the
organization itself with groups such as
the ethics committee keeping the
foundation's most hardline normalcy
supremacists from mistreating or
mishandling the objects they're supposed
to contain it's hard to imagine that
anything would slip by the ever watchful
eye of the foundation surveillance
network but in an organization this
large incidents are still bound to
happen while anomalies can be dangerous
the foundation as a whole backs the
ideal that they should be given ethical
treatment at least as much as they can
afford for safer less dangerous
anomalies this is a lot easier to
enforce to suggest rehabilitation
efforts and recreational privileges to
be given to an anomaly capable of ending
human life at a moment's notice raises a
lot more eyebrows even in the most
progressive sex of the foundation that
line becomes blurred when dealing with
intelligent entities what defines
intelligence sapience what distinguishes
scp-682
the indestructible lizard with a massive
disgust for all life from scp-239
an ultimately innocent little girl with
world breaking reality bending powers
this is the sort of argument that
divides the upper ranks of the
foundation is the integration of these
anomalies the answer or should they be
sealed away forever should they be
uniformly treated as monsters and freaks
unfit to ever leave their cells aside
from being used in testing fortunately
for the anomaly rights activists in the
crowd the modern foundation is much more
lenient than it had been in decades past
as research has proven that even
dangerous anomalies when given friendly
treatment and basic rights are more
compliant happy and feel less strife
about their situation they can even be
useful in some situations take
scp-5595 a sentient sarcastic gumball
machine located at site 322 whose
affinity for mathematics and harmless
nature earned it a position at the
site's accounting department as part of
a larger foundation initiative called
the integration program which focused on
integrating harmless anomalies into the
site itself in fact
scp-5595's accounting skills were so
great that it reduced site 322 spending
costs overall and opened the higher-ups
to the idea of integrating more
anomalies across the organization if you
need another example scp-999
the adorable orange blob lovingly
nicknamed the tickle monster
has been used as a therapy object at
site 19 for years but there is one side
of the debate that spurs more
controversy than any other using
anomalies as living weapons the
foundation is long long-abided by the
directive that its objects are to be
contained and studied instead of used in
the field as an uncontrollable object is
more dangerous outside of a cell than in
but the directive has changed especially
in recent times the chaos insurgency one
of the foundation's greatest foes
utilizes anomalies as weapons to achieve
their goals as do many other groups of
interest when trained human soldiers
just aren't enough to contend with all
the enemies the foundation deals with
it's no wonder they begin to explore
other options and that's what brings us
to the subject of today's video the tale
of scp-4793
an anomaly trained as a brutalizing
soldier who never really wanted to fight
this is the story of androcles a warrior
with a blazing savage fury in his body
but with a gentle tender longing in his
heart it all started during a foundation
raid on a chaos insurgency operation
located in a mountain cave in the
southern region of greece the deadly
insurgency always on the prowl for more
anomalous weapons to use in its unending
battle against the foundation had hired
a team of mercenaries to scour the
region for potential anomalous activity
they came across something buried in the
mountains they were certain was
anomalous and after communicating with
their superiors decided to dig it up and
see what it was about naturally word of
such a discovery travels fast and with
how many undercover operatives the
foundation keeps embedded inside the
insurgency in order to keep tabs on what
their enemies are doing it's no surprise
that the foundation mobilized its forces
to get the drop on whatever this
anomalous excavation site was the
mission was simple enough mtf upsilon 11
nicknamed avalon's wake a team of combat
specialists led by the skilled captain
holly shore would infiltrate their camp
and seize any anomalous objects in the
mercenary's possession getting past the
relatively unguarded entrance was a
cakewalk as the task force took out a
single guard and were able to slip
deeper into the cave undetected inside
they found a massive pit surrounded by
colorful stalagmites and flowing
waterfalls at the center of the pit next
to a smattering of camping supplies and
bright floodlights was a large stone
steely a type of pillar most often used
in ancient times that would be carved
with important messages or stories the
details were grainy from a distance but
the team could make out an engraved
image of a spartan hoplite soldier on
the pillar surrounding the steely were
five mercenaries armed and in the
process of digging out the pillar from
beneath the rock captain shore knew that
this was most likely the big object the
chaos insurgency were after she and her
team took cover waiting for the
opportune moment to strike but their
wait wasn't long one of the mercenaries
shoveling the ground near the steely let
out a scream they had cut themselves
splattering a small amount of blood on
the stone monument the mercenaries
panicked readying their arms they
weren't sure what was going to happen
next but with enough experience in the
field they knew that introducing an
anomaly to human blood often had severe
consequences and their suspicions were
proven correct a flash of light
surrounded the cave and from the steely
emerged a warrior clad in the same armor
as the spartan soldier engraved on the
monument's carving the entity was
clearly confused and asked in english if
the mercenary spoke greek instead they
thrust their guns forward screaming at
the soldier to not move the soldier was
compliant but one of the mercenaries
feeling it to be a cruel way to
establish dominance over their new
anomalous toy shot at the soldier's
exposed leg what happened next was a
whirlwind of swearing blood and combat
the mercenaries opened fire on the
soldier who retaliated back by using
powerful hand-to-hand combat for
whatever reason bullets just couldn't
seem to harm the soldier he tanked
dozens of open shots across his body the
rounds deflecting off his armor as the
soldier picked up a mercenary by the
throat the kevlar vest he was wearing
suddenly flung itself from the man's
body and integrated itself onto the
soldier's armor the mercenary
immediately recognized this as one of
the soldiers anomalous abilities but was
powerless to stop it as it was slammed
against the stone wall falling to the
ground the foundation task force watched
in awe as the soldier took out each of
the mercenaries one by one captain shore
seeing that the soldier was continually
begging the mercenaries to stop shooting
at it the entire time sense that there
was a peaceful humane side to the entity
a stark contrast to the acts of
brutality it used to dispatch the
mercenaries shore told their men to move
forward but with their weapons lowered
the soldier holding on to a knife he
grabbed earlier stood on guard but
surrendered without question when he
realized the foundation operatives were
not there to fight him captain short
introduced herself and her men as part
of the foundation and the soldier
clearly upset and distraught over the
carnage he caused introduced himself as
androcles the team promised androglies
they would take him somewhere safe and
he complied little would he know that
his journey with the foundation was just
beginning androcles was given the
designation scp-4793
an initial assessment found him to be
anomalously strong with the ability to
integrate any solid material into a
weapon either as a piece of armor like
it did with the mercenaries kevlar vest
or as a weapon itself such as turning
the steel leg of a chair into a
sharpened sword though this ability did
have its limits as entroples had
difficulty incorporating firearms and
complex electronics as weapons or armor
on top of that
scp-4793 was extremely durable and able
to heal any wounds on its body almost
instantaneously coupled with his highly
trained fighting skills and raging fury
androcles was a true warrior capable of
great power and might but his wild side
seemed to disappear when the heat of
battle died down one of site 20 senior
researchers dr fitzpatrick was tasked
with interviewing
scp-4793 weekly and she discovered that
scp-4793 had a completely different
element to his personality he was
intelligent kind gentle and hated
fighting he couldn't remember much of
his life from thousands of years ago but
he knew that he was a great warrior who
caused mass destruction with his power
alone androcles didn't want to be
someone like that he had an interest in
history in books and learning why he
woke up what the world was like now and
why it had changed androcles wanted to
know why there were metal birds in the
sky and horseless chariots on the ground
dr fitzpatrick found him to be a
remarkable person and commended
scp-4793 behavior with access to various
literature and history books so he could
learn about the things he desperately
wanted to know but most of all she was
taken back by how averse he was to
becoming his past self a heartless
warrior who killed indiscriminately it
seemed as if androcles was so
traumatized by his past actions that he
sealed away those memories to forget
about them as best he could but site
20's director jack hargrave saw
androcles as a mere tool something he
could use to achieve a nefarious goal he
had been planning for a long long time
hargraves wanted to use
scp-4793's raw power to benefit the
foundation from his office he sat back
imagining the unstoppable force that a
trained androcles would be if he could
force him to fight and he knew he could
then the foundation would have a deadly
weapon in their hands something that
would surely even the odds between the
chaos insurgency and those other pesky
groups of interest director hargraves
forced
scp-4793 to train his combat abilities
in a variety of sparring sessions with
captain shore the task force captain who
discovered him in the mountains
hargraves's regimen was brutal and he
often threatened to blow up the
explosive collars on
scp-4793's neck and wrists if he held
back against shore or disobeyed his
orders androcles could take the
explosion but shore would surely be
caught in the blast killing her
androcles hated hardraves but cared
about shore who showed him kindness and
understood his difficult position over
the next two years entroples would train
weekly with shore sparring with each
other using a variety of weapons from
swords to firearms
scp-4793 still held back not wanting to
fight and wanting even less to
accidentally injure holly shore who he
was growing to see
as a friend in the meantime dr
fitzpatrick continued to interview
scp-4793 weekly also growing a
friendship with the entity but for as
much as she cared about androcles she
couldn't help him the way she wanted to
hargraves was set on making
scp-4793 a functional weapon on the
field and he was growing impatient
waiting for results hargraves was
pushing enterprise beyond his comfort
zone switching up his sparring partners
from shore who he trusted deeply to
other individuals or changing what
weapons he had to use androcles hated
this not because he was scared to fight
but because he was anxious about what he
could become if he let loose he never
wanted to be the monster that he knew he
was capable of being he never wanted to
hurt someone in the meantime hargraves
began to have doubts about antarcleas
his humanity and reluctance would slow
him down in the field keep him from
being the perfect super soldier
hargraves wanted him to be zoe began
development on another project codenamed
x06 this mysterious weapons program was
kept under wraps limited in knowledge to
only har graves and his most trusted men
if he couldn't have androcles he would
simply have to do better and he knew he
would while hargraves worked in the
shadows the
scp-4793 research team uncovered a
section of androclee's past that he had
forgotten the steely he was trapped
inside had an inscription on its front
written in ancient greek when it was
translated and sent to dr fitzpatrick
this is what it read gather around me
children
i will tell you the story of sweet
androcles fierce as a pride of lions and
as cunning as a pack of wolves he lived
for nothing but battle he was beloved by
his countrymen and feared by his enemies
so much so that ares himself strode down
from olympus to challenge him to single
combat for ten days they fought a
terrible duel their blades cutting earth
into islands and the sparks turning
mountains into forges for hephaestus
impressed he granted androcles a boon so
long as he fought he would never know
defeat or age and by mixing his e corps
with androclee's blood aerys declared
him kin to the gods themselves as he
came to bear on the world he met his
match in a woman from a distant land
with skin of white as sand covered in
blues from the ocean she blazed in his
eyes like helios's chariot together the
mountains bowed before them but even as
arrows zazero brought them together an
arrow split them apart for jealous aries
saw his favored love something other
than himself with his guiding star gone
enter keys tore the bones of the earth
itself with his rage and lust for battle
extinguished he turned the battlefield
into twin mountains with his purpose
lost he was entombed there forevermore
androcles was shaken by the revelations
of his warrior past and in the present
he couldn't shake the feelings that
captain shore reminded him of his past
lover the feeling was so strong that
during a sparring session androcles
passed out overwhelmed by how much she
reminded him of her the woman who he
remembered to be his wife arabelle
andrew cleese continued to confide in dr
fitzpatrick about his feelings about
captain shore and especially about
fighting for the foundation he didn't
understand this strange new world or
what exactly he would be fighting for
and the stories he heard about previous
attempts to utilize anomalous soldiers
in battle terrified him the story of
scp-076
able killing his entire task force team
after losing control haunted him at
night he never wanted to become that but
hargraves's secret project reached its
completion before androcles could be
molded into the perfect warrior little
did hargraves know however that
fitzpatrick was keeping tabs on all of
his shady behavior in hopes of one day
exposing him for the monster that he was
to the ethics committee or maybe even
the overseer council still she took the
job wanting to see what monstrosity
hargraves had created as a result of his
experiments fitzpatrick was shocked to
see it hargrave's secret experiment was
a black winged clawed creature with way
too many teeth from behind its
containment cylinder it grinned and
chuckled an inhuman laugh hargraves was
truly creating monsters as hargraves
explained the creature had near human
intelligence and could reproduce
asexually meaning all it took was one of
them for it to multiply with this new
anomaly he could revolutionize the
foundation's ways of waging war a
perfect soldier one that wouldn't be
held back by human emotion fitzpatrick
voiced her concern but was cut short by
hargrave suddenly panicking he noticed
that there was only one x06 entity in
the cylinder when he was sure there were
two and suddenly from the ceiling one of
the entities fell to the ground clapping
its wings and screaming in the
researchers faces the worst had happened
the x06 entities had broken free and if
they weren't stopped soon they would run
rampant oversight 20. the two fled for
safety but the horrifying creature
chased after them androcles and captain
shore soon learned of the containment
breach as well after their sparring
session was cut short by a creature
breaking into the room androcles made
short work of it but it was too late
site-20 was overrun with hargraves as
beasts there were
hundreds of them and those numbers would
continue to grow they infiltrated the
entire facility leaving androcles and
captain shore with one option to fight
androcles didn't want to do it but this
was different he needed to be a hero and
save the people still trapped in sight
20s facilities he would have to use
force but if he was helping others then
it was justified he reluctantly told
himself still he hated it as captain
shore and her task force as well as
scp-4793 moved through site 20 taking
out one entity after another androcles
realized how hopeless the situation was
looking there were simply too many of
them they needed to focus their efforts
on getting people out to the site rather
than hoping to fight back while most
personnel were slaughtered in the
carnage at the site's d-class block the
team found a holdout of guards and
d-class who were conveniently relocated
to an above-ground elevator that could
escort them safely out of the site
androcles made the decision there to let
captain shore and her men as well as the
survivors get to the surface where he
would stay below and fight he didn't
want to do it but androcles had a plan
shaw didn't want to leave him behind but
she had no choice after parting in the
heat of an x-06 ambush on the block
andrew cleese was alone while the
survivors were on the surface fighting
without holding back androcle's tore
through hundreds of x06 entities going
deeper and deeper into the site his plan
was dangerous but it would save everyone
at the expense of his own life androcles
knew how dangerous those x06 entities
could be if they were let loose into the
world and that was why he decided he
would blow up site-20s reactor
destroying both himself the site and
every single creature as he was about to
do just that androcles found director
hargraves in the rubble of the reactor
room hargrave was heavily wounded and
androcles felt such rage and anger
towards the man especially when he
revealed that the x-06 creatures were
genetically engineered from androcles's
own blood but he didn't hurt him he was
better than the monster hargrave saw him
as instead hendrickley set hardgraves up
on the elevator to the surface knowing
that the overseer council would serve a
far worse punishment than he ever could
before blowing up the reactor androcles
recorded one last message he addressed
it to holly shore the captain who had
shown him so much kindness i was born to
a farmer and grew into a warrior i
battled ares to a standstill
i won war single-handedly then i met my
wife we were set to claim the world to
immortals who wanted to bring a chaotic
world some semblance of peace and then
aerys killed her and i
lost everything and now
i'm here alone adrift a stranger
surrounded by even stranger things but
within you
i see the spark i saw in her a burning
desire to make the world better it makes
me want to be better and i don't know if
you feel the same or whether i'll get
out of here but i will fight for you die
if i have to i
love you and with that androcles one of
the greatest warriors the foundation had
ever known sacrificed his life to blow
up site-20s nuclear reactor destroying
the facility and saving the world from
hargraves's deadly creatures to those
who knew him especially captain shore he
will never be forgotten because true
heroes never really die now go check out
what actually happened to major alexei
bellatrov
scp-2273 tail and scp-507 reluctant
dimension hopper for more journeys into
the lives and minds of the foundation's
most sympathetic prisoners